hallo ich bin anna willkommen
heute lernen wir die unterschiede
zwischen dem modell werben
hallo ich bin anna willkommen
heute lernen wir die unterschiede
zwischen dem modell werben
können
dürfen
sein
können
lassen müssen
sein
diese vier werben sind modell werben und
werden normalerweise mit anderen werben
im infiniti qx kombiniert
diese vier werben sind modell werben und
werden normalerweise mit anderen werben
im infiniti iv kombiniert
wir benutzen sie um ein bedürfnis
auszudrücken dass wir haben um etwas zu
tun
benutzen sie um ein bedürfnis
auszudrücken dass wir haben um etwas zu
tun
und diese handlung wird durch ein
zweites werk ausgedrückt
sie werden in ähnlichen zusammenhängen
verwendet
allerdings gibt es leichte unterschiede
in der bedeutung
sie werden in ähnlichen zusammenhängen
verwendet
allerdings gibt es leichte unterschiede
in der bedeutung
müssen und sollen
müssen wird im deutschen verwendet um
eine handlung auszudrücken die ich
entweder ausführen muss oder für die ich
keine andere wahl habe
müssen wird im deutschen verwendet um
eine handlung auszudrücken die ich
entweder ausführen muss oder für die ich
keine andere wahl habe
es drückt auch ein objektives bedürfnis
aus und klingt dringlicher
wenn du nicht tust was notwendig ist
musst du mit unangenehmen konsequenzen
rechnen
wenn du nicht tust was notwendig ist
musst du mit unangenehmen konsequenzen
rechnen
zur erinnerung infiniti iv müssen dritte
person muss präteritum musste partizip
zweige musst
zur erinnerung infiniti iv müssen dritte
person muss präteritum musste partizip
zweige musst
die konjugation von müssen im präsenz
ich muss
du musst
er muss wir müssen
ihr müsst sie oder sie müssen
konjugation von müssen im präsenz
ich muss
du musst
wir müssen
ihr müsst
oder sie müssen schauen wir uns einige
beispiele an
ich muss in die schule gehen um zu
lernen
lernen wenn sonja nicht zur schule geht
um zu lernen wird sie nicht in der lage
sein auf die uni zu gehen
oder später einen job zu bekommen wenn
sonja nicht zur schule geht um zu lernen
wird sie nicht in der lage sein auf die
uni zu gehen
oder später einen job zu bekommen morgen
muss ich zur arbeit gehen
morgen muss ich zur arbeit gehen wenn
john morgen nicht zur arbeit geht kann
ihm sein chef kündigen
wenn schon morgen nicht zur arbeit geht
kann ihm sein chef kündigen
helena muss ihre schulden bezahlen
helena muss ihre schulden bezahlen wenn
helena ihre schulden nicht bezahlt
könnte sie ihr haus verlieren wenn
könnte sie ihr haus verlieren
matthias ist sehr krank sie müssen ihn
ins krankenhaus bringen wenn sie
matthias nicht ins krankenhaus bringen
könnte er sterben
matthias ist sehr krank sie müssen ihn
ins krankenhaus bringen wenn sie
matthias nicht ins krankenhaus bringen
könnte er sterben
ich will in deutschland leben
alexa möchte in deutschland leben
um in deutschland selbstständig leben zu
können muss sie deutsch sprechen und
verstehen können
um in deutschland selbstständig leben zu
können muss sie deutsch sprechen und
verstehen können
ohne deutschkenntnisse wird das leben in
deutschland für sie schwierig sein
heute muss ich die wäsche machen
diese woche habe ich viel zu tun und ich
kann es nicht an einem anderen tag
machen
diese woche habe ich viel zu tun und ich
kann es nicht an einem anderen tag
machen
er muss heute die wäsche waschen weil er
ihr später keine zeit mehr dafür haben
wird
er muss heute die wäsche waschen weil er
später keine zeit mehr dafür haben wird
ich musste heute morgen mit dem hund
raus
wenn ronald seinen hund nicht aus für
pinkl da ins haus
wenn ronald seinen hund nicht ausführt
pinkl alten songs
denke daran dass das zweite im satz
verwendete werk immer ans ende gesetzt
wird
denke daran dass das zweite im satz
verwendete wer immer ans ende gesetzt
wird
es ist üblich dass das zweite werk gehen
beim sprechen weggelassen wird
hier ist in ein paar beispiele
andré muss zum bäcker gehen
andré muss zum bei
andré muss zum bäcker
ich muss in die schule gehen
ich muss in die schule
das verb sollen zeigt normalerweise eine
bitte oder einen befehl einer anderen
person an
das verb sonnenzeit normalerweise eine
bitte oder einen befehl einer anderen
person an die person kann diese bitte
nützlich finden oder nicht
die person kann diese bitte nützlich
finden oder nicht
mit anderen worten es ist eine handlung
die ich aus führen soll
aber ohne jede verpflichtung
mit anderen worten es ist eine handlung
die ich aus führen soll
aber ohne jede verpflichtung die bitte
bezieht sich oft auf handlungen die für
unser wohlbefinden oder zur verbesserung
von etwas getan werden sollten
die bitte bezieht sich oft auf
handlungen die für unser wohlbefinden
oder zur verbesserung von etwas getan
werden sollten
zur erinnerung infiniti iv sollen dritte
person soll
präteritum sollte partizip zwei gewollt
zur erinnerung infiniti iv sollen dritte
person soll
präteritum sollte partizip zwei gewollt
konjugation von sollen im präsenz ich
soll
du sollst er soll wir sollen
ihr sollt sie oder sie sollen
konjugation von sollen im präsens ich
soll
du sollst er soll wir sollen
ihr sollt sie oder sie sollen
schauen wir uns einige beispiele an
carol soll medizin studieren
die eltern von carol wollen dass carol
medizin studiert
es geht nicht darum ob carol es will
oder für wichtig hält
amanda hat die grippe
[Musik]
sie soll einen heißen tee trinken
amanda hat die grippe
amanda kann den rat befolgen damit es
ihr wieder besser geht
sie muss es aber nicht machen
amanda kann den rat befolgen damit es
ihr wieder besser geht
sie muss es aber nicht machen
du sollst nicht so viel fluchen
karls eltern wollen nicht dass er so
viele flucht
wir sollen jeden tag unsere hausaufgaben
machen
machen die lehrerin sagt dass wir unsere
hausaufgaben machen müssen damit wir die
grammatik lernen können
wir haben aber keine lust dazu die
lehrerin sagt dass wir unsere
hausaufgaben machen müssen damit wie die
grammatik lernen können wir haben aber
keine lust dazu können und dürfen
normalerweise wird können verwendet um
die fähigkeit von jemandem auszudrücken
zum beispiel er kann sehr gut deutsch
sprechen
ich kann sehr gut tanzen
er kann gut fußball spielen
[Applaus]
lucia kann schöne bilder malen
sie können schnell schwimmen
ich kann deutsch sprechen
du kannst gitarre spielen
[Musik]
er kann ein pferd reiten
zur erinnerung infiniti iv können dritte
person kann rät um konnte partizip zwei
gekonnt zur erinnerung infiniti iv
können dritte person kann rät um konnte
partizip zwei gekonnt
konjugation von können im präsens
ich kann du kannst er kann
wir können
ihr könnt sie oder sie können
konjugation von können im präsens
ich kann du kannst er kann
wir können
ihr könnt sie oder sie können
die konjunktiv 2 verwendung des verbs
können wird manchmal verwendet um eine
höfliche bitte zu äußern
die konjunktiv 2 verwendung des verbs
können wird manchmal verwendet um eine
höfliche bitte zu äußern
beispiel könnten sie mir bitte meinen
koffer reichen
könnte ich hier sitzen
könnte ich hier sitzen könnten sie uns
bitte nicht so früh anrufen ja klar
es tut mir leid
könnten sie uns bitte nicht so früh
anrufen ja klar
es tut mir leid
wir können dieses werk auch im
konjunktiv 2 verwenden um hypothesen
über die zukunft aufzustellen
wir können dieses werk auch im
konjunktiv 2 verwenden um hypothesen
über die zukunft aufzustellen
morgen könnte ein schöner tag werden
mein lieblingsteam könnte das spiel
morgen gewinnen mein lieblingsteam
könnte das spiel morgen gewinnen
john könnte in ein paar monaten
befördert werden
wir könnten und das stück am
donnerstagabend ansehen
das nächste werk ist dürfen
wenn es darum geht um erlaubnis zu
fragen verwenden wir normalerweise
dürfen was korrekt und auch höflicher
ist
wenn es darum geht um erlaubnis zu
fragen verwenden wir normalerweise
dürfen was korrekt und auch höflicher
ist
dieses werk wird verwendet um erlaubnis
zu geben oder sie zu verweigern
sie dürfen hier schwimmen
sie dürfen hier schwimmen das rauchen
ist an diesem ort nicht erlaubt das
rauchen ist an diesem ort nicht erlaubt
sie dürfen hier also nicht rauchen
sie dürfen hier weder essen noch trinken
es ist erlaubt wasser aus dem brunnen zu
trinken
sie dürfen hier also aus dem brunnen
es ist erlaubt wasser aus dem brunnen zu
trinken
sie dürfen hier also aus dem brunnen
trinken darf ich kurz ihren computer
benutzen ja sie dürfen ihn verwenden
darf ich kurz ihren computer benutzen ja
sie dürfen ihn verwenden darf ich mal
kurz ihr bad benutzen darf ich mal kurz
im bad benutzen ja sie dürfen es
verwenden
ja sie dürfen es verwenden
darf ich mal kurz ihr telefon benutzen
klar sie dürfen mein telefon jederzeit
benutzen klar
sie dürfen mein telefon jederzeit
benutzen
zur erinnerung infiniti iv dürfen
dritte person darf präteritum durfte
partizip zwei gedurft zur erinnerung
infiniti iv dürfen
dritte person darf präteritum durfte
partizip zwei gedurft konjugation von
dürfen im präsenz
ich darf
du darfst
er darf
wir dürfen
ihr dürft sie oder sie dürfen
konjugation von dürfen im präsens
ich darf
du darfst
er darf
wir dürfen
ihr dürft oder sie dürfen so jetzt bist
du an der reihe
so jetzt bist du an der reihe schreib
uns vier sätze mit den werten die wir
heute gelernt haben
schreibt uns vier sätze mit den werben
die wir heute gelernt haben müssen
sollen können dürfen freunde wenn euch
das video gefallen hat gib uns bitte
einen like freunde wenn euch das video
gefallen hat gibt uns bitte einen like
abonniere uns und volk uns auf allen
unseren sozialen netzwerken
bleibt mit uns am ball und lernt fleißig
deutsch
bis zum nächsten mal